Want to play a game? Netflix's smash hit "Squid
Game" is coming back with a vengeance in 2024,
and the streaming company's quick teaser
gives us just enough to speculate on.
"Squid Game" took Netflix by storm in
2021, with the South Korean hit becoming
the streaming service's most-watched
original series at the time. Since then,
fans have been treated to a reality TV spin-off
called "Squid Game: The Challenge" as they wait
for the main show to return. The good news,
however, is that the wait is almost over,
as Netflix has released a tantalizing
teaser for "Squid Game" Season 2.
The clip picks up from where the Season 1 finale
left off, as Gi-hun walks through an airport,
and he's out for revenge against the Squid
Game's founders. The winner of the titular
deadly competition speaks with one of the
game's mysterious organizers on the phone,
who tells Gi-hun that he'll regret the decision to
disobey him. However, Gi-hun isn't intimidated by
the threat as he promises to find his enemy
and end the Squid Game once and for all.
"Squid Game" Season 2 looks set to be
an action-packed and bloody affair that
will dig deeper into the lore of
this universe. With that in mind,
let's anticipate what we can expect from the
next installment of Netflix's international hit.
"Squid Game" Season 1 ends with Seong Gi-hun
being financially well-off but feeling more
unfulfilled than ever. He learns that his old
friend Contestant 001 is still alive, even
though he's terminally ill, and not the humble,
good man he thought he was. It turns out that the
old man is one of the masterminds behind the Squid
Game, as he and his rich friends created it as a
means of entertainment. Naturally, this upsets
Gi-hun, and he isn't willing to stand for it.
"You put us through all
that… so you could have fun?"
The Season 2 teaser confirms that Gi-hun will
be out to take down the creators of the deadly
game and put a stop to their barbarity.
Sporting a new red hairdo and a desire to
end the corruption, Gi-hun has gone from being a
down-on-his-luck everyman to a vengeful warrior,
but is he strong enough to stop this entire
operation on his own? Only time will tell.
While speaking to The Hollywood Reporter,
creator Hwang Dong-hyuk said the next
installment will also explore the backstory
of the man who recruits Gi-hun for the Squid
Game in Season 1. Additionally, he detailed
plans to dig into the story of The Front Man
and Gi-Hun's family history. It remains to be
seen what's in store for viewers, but at least
they won't have long to wait. "Squid Game"
Season 2 will be released sometime this year.